opponents of President Morsy have been
preparing for a mass protest march
demonstrators have come to Cairo from
all across the country on the one-year
anniversary of Morrissey taking power
they have come to demand he stepped down
I began rosella I would like to send a
message to Morsi today is his last day
to rule the country he lost his
legitimacy and failed I also want to say
to him he should step down before you
face Mubarak's fait mal CE Rafael corner
samasya nawara vertices supporters have
also been gathering to celebrate the
anniversary of the president's
swearing-in they point out that he is
Egypt's first democratically elected
head of state well if his performance in
the past year doesn't meet the standards
of the people they have the right to
protest and peacefully demonstrate
without destroying things there are
tools for democracy which was set forth
by the Constitution which two-thirds of
the Egyptian people agreed to the store
many opposition supporters boycotted the
vote on the country's post-revolution
constitution some say they fear Egypt is
being turned into an Islamist State we
are now at a point where it's either us
or them if people give up too easily
today then everyone will go home and it
would be as if nothing happened and we
can't let our country slip away when in
fashion see by Ladner dominator
demonstrators have said they will stay
on the streets until Morsi steps down
the situation in the Egyptian capital
remains tense
you